das ist das neue Album von Thomas D
Lektionen in Demut 11.0 wobei die 11te
Version stimmt nicht ganz es ist die
zweite Version vor 10 Jahren hat er
schon mal ein Album gleichen Namens
produziert ist ein ganz bisschen anders
als die Fantastischen Vier erinnert mir
so an Poetry Slam also sensationelle
Texte aber auch sensationelle Musik
darüber wollen wir mit ihm reden und
natürlich über vieles mehr und über eure
nutzerfragen die wollen wir beantworten
die besten kommen dran also lasst euch
was einfallen und ladet sie am besten
als Video hoch lest den V Tex und dann
kann eigentlich nichts mehr schiefgehen
ich drücke die
Daumen